this comes to mind because of the movie
you just did which I watched and I
really loved where your your your your
roleplay where you're doing all these
amazing badass stunts you're basically
playing a mom who's also uh an assassin
and it's really physical and you're
really good at it thank you and and I'm
like this is Major some keano Reeves
moves in here and and I was thinking
what was the timeline was this after you
I landed in Germany I shot it in Germany
it landed in Germany and then we found
it a week later I was pregnant and I
went in for my first day of stunt
training I was pregnant that's insane I
Know I Was Pregnant that whole time it
was wild also we shot in Berlin in the
summer it was like a th000 degrees and
all I wanted was Taco Bell and they
don't have Taco Bell in all of Germany I
looked I searched it's all I wanted but
also I didn't tell anyone I was pregnant
so all they kept thinking was this girl
keeps asking for Taco Bell won't let us
very sweaty I won't let it call her mama
and her stunt double seems to be
interfering with a lot she saying like
I'll do that I'll do that cuz I told her
you told your stunt okay that's good
told my stunt double but you're clearly
I mean I watch movie and you were doing
a lot and and there's no way that's like
nope they did not CGI your head onto
that person's body you're doing a lot of
these uh stunts and you're pregnant
while you're doing it obviously early on
but still that's got to be in your head
a little bit it was more it wasn't the
physicality I the that I was sick the
whole time so I was just so I wanted to
die the entire time it just I just was
sick I was just nauseous so the physical
stuff I actually felt better cuz I was
like moving around but when I would just
have to sit there and like say dialogue
I just was like seeing white um but yeah
it was a wild it was a wild experience I
wouldn't recommend it when I I was like
oops what if but what if what if your
baby now just has that
you know just because it was she was in
utero what if she now she can she's in
stunt classes now doing sword fighting I
mean I told you she's 10 months today
yeah sword fight yeah this is the time
to get her going in that so sword
fighting and you know all all those
sorts of things that's funny that you
want to Taco Bell my wife was uh
vegetarian when I met her and so then we
get married she finds out she's pregnant
okay everything's moving along fine we
go out to this place in New York uh and
I order a burger because I'm Irish
Catholic and for me that's a
well-rounded healthy meal absolutely and
uh so I get my burger and she gets her
salad and I'll never forget she said
Liza said can um can I just have one
bite of your burger and she had never
been interested at all in any of the
giant Flintstone steaks I was eating or
anything and she said can I just have
one bite of your burger and I went uh
okay and I held it over the table and
she took a bite and then didn't let go
oh my God and then I I swear to God her
jaw
detached like a snake and she pushed it
and my fist into her mouth and inhaled
it and bye-bye no more vegetarian like
because it was no longer her in charge
it was our daughter inside saying it's
Burger Time and and pulling a lever yes
she still eat meat yes so it's so crazy
so I also was a vegetarian I hadn't
eaten meat in like probably seven or
eight years and my my fiance my
partner's big mediator too and this
exact story happened to us you and I was
like I want that and I was it's the same
thing and I said I have to have that
he's like you you have it and I ate the
whole steak and I now like only eat
steak your cholesterol yeah 7,000 dying
but yeah this is my last you've had six
heart attacks since you came in here I
have no but it's crazy and I I now I eat
meat which is nuts and I didn't for
years um but it was the second that I
wase got pregnant yeah and it's it's
funny because at the time I asked my dad
who's a doctor and uh I said to him
isn't that something and he went ah the
passenger is now in
charge that's so crazy yeah yeah and uh
he had this little smile like ah yes the
passenger I'm like what are you suddenly
talking in this weird
code you've been to medical school you
can say that the the the child in utero
wants protein no the passenger has taken
control of the vessel
what my God he's like he's like Kane and
Kung Fu you knowly wandering the Earth
saying this weird stuff
he